نعم بالطبع يمكن للناس أن يروا أن
الأسعار قد ارتفعت سعر الطاقة
سعر الوقود للكهرباء
أه
سعر الغاز المنزلي للطعام الغذاء مكلف للغاية
الكثير من المزارعين غير قادرين على أه
حصاد حقولهم حتى يتمكن عامة
الناس من رؤيتها  التضخم يرتفع ولكن
أيضًا الناس العاديين صُدموا مما
تفعله روسيا في أوكرانيا ، لقد
صُدموا تمامًا ولذا عليهم
أن يدركوا ولكن يجب
القيام بشيء ما وأعتقد أنك
تعرف ثمن ذلك هو تطبيق
عقوبات ضد روسيا  ضد من
يرتكب
جريمة إنسانية جرائم
حرب
أنواع وهذا ثمن علينا دفع
العقوبات ضد أه ضد روسيا
لأننا بالطبع نريد أه
التضامن مع أه الشعب الأوكراني
الذي يناضل من أجل السلام
والازدهار في بلدهم لذلك أنا  فكر
وأحد الأمثلة على ذلك أن إيطاليا
أيضا صوتت
لمنح الأوروبيين السلاح للدفاع عن أنفسهم
والدفاع عن ديمقراطيتهم والدفاع
عن أه حريتهم مرة أخرى  في حالة الغزو الروسي ،
فإنه يخبرك أن هناك
استجابة قوية من قبل الدول
الأوروبية والشعوب الأوروبية خائفة مما
تفعله روسيا ، وقد صدمتهم
هذه الأنواع من الحروب وهم أيضًا
منشغلون جدًا لأن هذا
التضخم يخاطر بتعريض اقتصادنا للخطر.
الانتعاش
أمريكا ، الولايات المتحدة هي أكبر شريك لأوروبا ،
نحن في نفس الوقت في الدفاع عن
الديمقراطيات الليبرالية ومع إذا أردنا أن يكون
لدينا ثلاث دول في نيبال الكاثوليكية
بالطبع ، فقد ارتكبت الولايات المتحدة بعض
الأخطاء الفظيعة
وأيضًا بعض المآسي
بالتفكير في حرب العراق التي كانت ضد العراق تمامًا ،
لم نرغب في المشاركة
حتى تعرف أن
السياسة الخارجية للولايات المتحدة هي شيء
نتفق معه مع الرجل عدة مرات ولكن
ليس كل هذا الوقت الآن حول
الحالتين اللتين تحدثت عنهما عن
إعادة تعريف العلاقة مع
فنزويلا وإيران
أه إنه شيء لا يزال مبكرًا
يستحق الثناء ولكن بالطبع لا يمكنك
دائمًا محاربة كل الأعداء  ر مرة واحدة
وبالطبع إذا أردنا أن أه
الضغط على روسيا علينا التوقف عن
شراء الغاز والنفط الروسي
وهذا يعني العثور على النفط والغاز والغاز في
مكان آخر ، لذا أفترض أن هذا أيضًا جزء
من المعادلة لماذا أفترض أن
هناك إعادة تدفئة  العلاقة مع
بعض هذه المقاطعات
أيضًا ، أعتقد أيضًا أنك تعرف عن إيران
تذكر أن هناك صفقة تم إبرامها
في الماضي ، لذا آمل
أن يتم التوصل إلى اتفاق جديد للقتال
من أجل إيجاد السلام والحصول على
سلام بين إيران
والغرب وفنزويلا ، أنا قلق للغاية
بشأن هذا البلد وأعتقد أن النظام
فظيع لما يفعله لسكانه ،
إنه البلد الذي يحتوي
على أكبر
كمية من احتياطيات النفط في العالم
ومع ذلك فإن سكانه  تحتضر من الفقر
ولا يمكنها حتى العثور على ورق تواليت
في محلات السوبر ماركت ، لذا الآن بخصوص هذه
القضايا المحددة أه من الصعب
الحضور ومن السابق لأوانه التعليق
ولكن بالتأكيد السياسة الخارجية للولايات المتحدة السياسة
الخارجية الأوروبية  الشرطة الأجنبية الجليدية والأجنبية
منقسمون
عدة مرات ، وفي كثير من الأحيان ، يكونون
معًا في بعض الأحيان صالحًا جدًا ، كما تعلمون ،
لذلك في أوكرانيا ، نحن متحدون تمامًا
في إدانة الهجوم الروسي